Okay, now let's break up the Demographic
and the Geographic segments.
So the Demographic segmentation is,
you guessed it,
based on your customers Demographic
characteristics, things like age,
gender, occupation, education level,
income level, and much more.
If you're coming from a B2B or
a business to business point of view,
this could be the size of the company,
the number of employees, or
even the location of the company.
Now for
the Geographic segmentation, this is
just segmented by geographic areas.
such as the country, regions,
different cities, postal codes.
Now, you can do a geo-cluster approach,
which combines Demographic and
Geographic segmentations.
You'll look at demographic
information within a certain area
To create a more specific profile.
Do your graphic segmentation
is really important for
international marketing,
it's usually your first step.
So an example of a Geographic
segmentation would be
warm climates versus cold.
Climates.
Now you're probably better off
marketing the coats you make
to a cooler climate than you
are to a warmer climate.
Just as bathing suits might
not sell as as well in
Alaska as they would in Brazil or
the Caribbean.